hey guys this is Johnny Dutchess and
this is the 2020 census explained by
puppies kittens and a pregnant lady this
is gonna be way too much fun you guys
this year you can complete the 2020
census online or by phone or by mail
that's great this is the first year that
it's available online which makes it
easy for me because I can sit here and
play with the puppies as much as I want
college students who live away from home
should be counted at the on or
off-campus residence where they live and
sleep most of the time
the 2020 census will inform how we spend
hundreds of billions of dollars in
federal funds every year pet stores can
use 2020 census data to help decide
where to put new stores they like the
facts one of the big census data will
help inform is where to build new roads
hey a fresh concrete thank you this
census never asks for Social Security or
credit card numbers so that means your
stuff is protected okay the 2020 census
doesn't count pets but it does count
everyone living in the 50 states DC and
five US territories even newborn babies
need to be counted even if they're still
in the hospital the census determines
how many seats and the House of
Representatives each state gets good
thing to know will you help me get one
is harder than I thought okay
the results of the 2020 census will
inform how billions of dollars in
federal funding are allocated to many
programs including Medicaid headstart
grants for mental health services and so
much more thank you for that the US
Census Bureau is bound by law to protect
your answers and keep them strictly
confidential did you it's important to
count all your roommates on the census
and there you have it make sure you
complete the 2020 census